[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de Franz 24 después de Clint y
Venecia las piscinas de luces en la
ciudad francesa de burdeos acogen ahora
a dos exposiciones digitales inmersivas
sobre artistas catalanes el pintor
Salvador Dalí y el arquitecto Anthony
gaudí una experiencia visual confundo de
música psicodélica que recorrió nuestra
corresponsal en Francia Erica olavaría
un joven Salvador Dalí saliendo de las
aguas del cap de creus su hermana Ana
María en la ventana y la costa
mediterránea las obras del conocido
artista Catalán adornan por estos días
las aguas y muros de las piscinas de
luces de burdeos El más grande centro de
arte digital del mundo con 45.000 metros
cuadrados literalmente esta antigua base
de submarinos construida por los nazis
durante la Segunda Guerra invita a
sumergirse en esta exposición inmersiva
somos el más grande centro de arte
digital del mundo con una centena de
video proyectores y 80 altavoces
especializados las proyecciones se
reflejan en el suelo y los muros y
nuestra gran plusvalía es que aún
tenemos las piscinas que acogían esos
submarinos con agua y todas las imágenes
se reflejan en el agua para sublimar aún
más las obras de los artistas
[Música]
desde sus experiencias en el teatro
pasando por sus citas al arte clásico
sus telas gigantes sus retratos de gala
o el atomismo cada una de las etapas del
artista es representada en estas
proyecciones
incluidas las joyas que diseñó y por si
fuera aún necesaria más inspiración la
música de Los británicos Pink Floyd
acompaña en este viaje subterráneo
[Música]
para una exposición inmersiva yo creo
que este debo cumplir
creo que es más que un pintor es alguien
que hizo de su vida y de su personaje
una obra de arte
y con la música de Pink Floyd podemos
realmente viajar en su cerebro como él
pedía vengan vengan vengan a mi cerebro
[Música]
las obras de otro Catalán se unen a las
de Dalí en esta muestra Antonio gaudí el
arquitecto con una imaginación tan rica
como la del artista parecía su más
evidente compañero en este recorrido la
sagrada familia la casa valió la Pedrera
y hasta el parque buey desfilan ante Los
visitantes iluminando de colores la
oscuridad de este sitio cargado de
historia
[Música]
nos quedamos con el arte visual para
hablar ahora de los galardones de cine
que cerraron el mes de febrero empezando
con la mayor ceremonia del cine francés
los premios se da la película que se
robó el protagonismo de esta edición
número 48 fue la noche del 12 un
Thriller policiaco basado en un
feminicidio real la cinta ganó seis
estatuillas incluido un doblete poco
frecuente mejor película y mejor
director para Dominic y otro intenso
Thriller ganó el César a la mejor
película extranjera asbestas del español
Rodrigo
rodada en el campo de Galicia y con un
elenco impecable ya había triunfado en
los premios españoles Goya el pasado 11
de febrero llevándose nueve galardones
del lado de Alemania el festival de la
berlina le consagró con su premio más
prestigioso del oso de oro al empático
documental francés
que sigue a pacientes con enfermedades
mentales pero en esta edición número 73
los ojos estaban apuestos en la actriz
española Sofía Otero que con solo nueve
años se alzó al uso de plata a mejor
actuación por su papel de niña trans en
la cinta 20.000 especies de abejas de
solapas
ya unos días de los Oscar una ceremonia
un poco menos conocida por el público
los premios del sindicato de actores del
audiovisual estadounidense recompensó a
la brillante y extravagante todo en
todas partes al mismo tiempo de los seis
premios dedicados al cine cuatro
llegaron a manos de su elenco el
apasionado discurso de su patriarca
James
de 94 años marco además la gala lo
escuchamos mi primera película fue con
Clark cable pero en aquella época tengo
que decirles esto
en la buena tierra el papel protagonista
lo interpretaban Estos tipos con ojos
tapados así y hablaban así
porque el productor decía los asiáticos
no eran lo bastante buenos y no son
taquilleros
pero míranos ahora
cerramos nuestro programa con nuestra
sección dedicada a la música
enfocándonos en dos álbumes que marcaron
este mes de febrero La Estrella
Colombiana Karol G publicó su cuarto y
más sincero proyecto mañana será bonito
en 17 temas mezclando los ritmos de
reggaeton con melodías y voces pop Karol
G cuenta las secuelas de una ruptura y
celebrar las fiestas y las amistades
Para sanar el dolor es además un albón
lleno de poderosas colaboraciones con
entre otras su compatriota Shakira pero
también dos figuras del dancehall el
jamaica y la española
[Música]
y en el planeta rapel reconocido rapero
belgo marroquí amsa estreno también un
nuevo álbum personal
sinceramente una vulnerabilidad
controlada y muy bien producida lo que
siempre caracteriza este artista
camaleónico que evoluciona entre una
hora
duro y incisivo y notas de electrodo
Nos despedimos con Winx la nueva canción
del famoso trío de hermanos
estadounidenses los Jonas Brothers
Gracias a ustedes por su confianza y
sigan con nosotros hay más cultura en
France 24 y Francia 24.com
[Música]